Traductor: Analia Padin
Revisor: Paula Motter
¿Cómo explicar lo inexplicable?
Esta pregunta ha inspirado
numerosos mitos,
prácticas religiosas
e investigaciones científicas.
Pero los budistas zen que practicaban
en China entre el siglo IX y el siglo XIII
se hacían una pregunta diferente:
¿por qué necesitamos una explicación?
Para estos monjes,
buscar respuestas ciegamente
era un vicio a superar,
y aprender a aceptar
los misterios de la existencia
era el verdadero camino
hacia la iluminación.
Pero puede ser difícil resistir
el deseo de explicar lo inexplicable.
Para practicar cómo vivir
con estos misterios,
los monjes meditaban
con unos 1700 experimentos filosóficos
ambiguos y desconcertantes
llamados "kōans",
El nombre, originalmente gong-an en chino,
significa "archivo de casos públicos".
Pero los kōans, a diferencia
de las causas judiciales reales,
eran intencionalmente incomprensibles.
Eran sorprendentes, surrealistas
y frecuentemente contradictorios.
A simple vista, contenían un proverbio
sobre el código monástico budista zen,
como vivir sin ataduras
materiales o mentales,
evitar el pensamiento binario
y alcanzar la propia "naturaleza de Buda".
Presentadas en el marco
de una anécdota ilógica,
estas lecciones eran pruebas
que ayudaban a los monjes
a vivir con la ambigüedad y la paradoja.
Al meditar sobre estos casos confusos,
los monjes interiorizaban y practicaban
las enseñanzas budistas,
con la esperanza de poder abandonar
la búsqueda de una respuesta única
y tener una revelación espiritual.
Como estas historias son
intencionalmente inexplicables,
no sería una buena idea
tratar de descifrarlas.
Pero, al igual que aquellos monjes,
podemos reflexionar juntos
e investigar lo difícil que resulta
encontrar una explicación simple.
Consideren este kōan que ilustra
la práctica del desapego.
Dos monjes, Tanzan y Ekido,
marchan por un camino embarrado.
Más adelante, ven una bella viajera
que no puede cruzar el sendero de lodo.
Tanzan se ofrece gentilmente a ayudarla,
la carga sobre sus espaldas
hasta el otro lado del camino
y la deposita sin decir una palabra.
Ekido queda estupefacto.
Según la ley monástica, los monjes
no deben acercarse a las mujeres,
y mucho menos tocar
a una bella desconocida.
Luego de varios kilómetros de caminata,
Ekido no pudo contenerse y preguntó:
"¿Cómo pudiste cargar a esa mujer?".
Tanzan sonrió: "Yo la dejé allí.
¿Y tú? ¿Todavía la estás cargando?".
Como todos los kōans, esta historia
tiene muchas interpretaciones.
Pero una de las más comunes
sugiere que, pese a no haber cargado
nunca a la viajera sobre sus espaldas,
Ekido infringió la ley monástica
por aferrarse mentalmente a la mujer.
Este tipo de conflicto,
que examina la zona gris
entre el texto y el significado de la ley,
era muy común en los kōans.
Además de examinar la ambigüedad,
muchas veces los kōans
ridiculizaban a los personajes
que se atribuían un entendimiento
absoluto del mundo circundante.
Un ejemplo es la historia de tres monjes
que discuten acerca del estandarte
que flamea encima del templo.
El primer monje dice
que el estandarte se mueve,
mientras que el segundo afirma
que no ve la bandera moverse
sino el viento que sopla.
Entablan una discusión por el tema
hasta que interviene un tercer monje:
"Lo que se mueve no es
ni la bandera ni el viento:
son sus mentes".
Una posible interpretación gira en torno
a la supuesta sabiduría de los monjes.
Para el primero, lo importante
es el mundo que podemos percibir;
para el segundo, el conocimiento profundo
que podemos inferir del mundo.
Pero, al estar fijados
en sus propias "respuestas",
ninguno de los dos monjes
ve el punto de vista del otro
y de ese modo contradicen
un ideal fundamental del budismo:
evitar el pensamiento binario.
El tercer monje interpreta que se trata
de un conflicto de percepción:
ninguno de los dos monjes
es capaz de ver el panorama completo.
Es claro que todas estas interpretaciones
no son más que pistas
para abordar los kōans.
Ni la sabiduría de los monjes
que practicaron antes que nosotros
ni los personajes supuestamente
sabios en estas historias
pueden resolverlos por nosotros.
Esto es porque el objetivo de los kōans
no es encontrar a una simple solución.
Es justamente el acto de luchar
con estos enigmas paradójicos
lo que desafía nuestro deseo
de encontrar una solución
y nuestro entendimiento
del entendimiento mismo.